Jack Casady is back on the voice
[Music]
Alysha I'm so honored and humbled to
work with you you're amazing
just one week after Alicia Keys said
goodbye to the singer during knockout
rounds of the competition show she
surprised David Cassidy's nephew by
bringing him back during Monday's
episode I want you to go home so you're
gonna be my coming back either no this
is locally the biggest song as diamond
oh I don't know just relive her deliver
he did Jack performed Elton John's don't
let the Sun go down on me on Monday
night's episode and crushed it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Alicia was clearly proud to have him
back on the team it's just such a
blessing because you know it's something
that Gwen and I would talk about earlier
I know oh my gosh I think we all have it
inside of us there's this greatness
inside of us and sometimes it's so scary
and I saw that in you and I see that in
myself sometimes and so I'm I'm rooting
for you and so tonight I was I knew you
were gonna do this what you did nothing
else you should always see your
greatness here tonight on that stage and
that is the most important incredible
thing and I know your family is home
going crazy for this performance
[Applause]
[Music]
you